this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
hello everyone welcome to the Sanford
seminar on people computers in design
next week we're going to have James land
a from the University of Washington
talking about his research on world lab
building a research group that connects
folks in chinua with folks in in the
u.s. at the University of Washington and
this week we have Eric Paulo's I've
known Erika very long time he and I were
lab mates in graduate school and one of
my favorite things about the seminar is
that many of the most memorable talks
for me are people who weren't simply
doing some of the best work on their
field but rather they figured out some
way to create a new research area or a
new research direction or a new research
aesthetic that really they move forward
a whole way of thinking and Eric's work
for me has embodied that for a very long
time he's figured out how to combine
real technical skill in robotics with a
real interest in the aesthetic
experience of robots and other
technology one early research project of
Eric's was he developed a system called
props a personal roving presence and
they were blimps and robots where you
could be telepresence in some location
and in fact the first time that a prop
was ever demonstrated live in person was
in this very seminar series about 15
years ago and now there are many groups
at Mozilla and Microsoft and others who
are building similar kind of
technologies and so Eric was really
prescient in that and so now we get to
hear about the thing that 15 years from
now we'll be saying we first saw here
Eric great thank you Scott it's a
pleasure to be at here at Stanford I
always have so many good memories of all
my visits here a lot of great colleagues
that I have huge admiration for it's
also great to be back in the bay area so
i was at carnegie mellon university for
the last few years in the human-computer
interaction institute and now i'm back
at UC berkeley and the electro
engineering computer science department
but also part of this bc NM which is the
berkeley center for new media i'll just
briefly say it's this
around looking at how practitioners from
other fields can talk about media and
culture and technology and there's a lot
of synergies outside of just computer
science and so I'm really excited to be
part of that this is not a prop this is
my son and his Halloween costume he
wanted to be a robot this is the problem
if you are a roboticist you can't be
outdone by other people in your
neighborhood on the robot costume anyway
let me just tell you hopefully we'll
have a little discussion about some some
things that I think are exciting and
compelling and we'll see where we go
from there I want to say a couple things
one thing is that the way that I often I
work and work with my colleagues is more
on sort of this ethos of problem making
rather than problem solving I like to
collage ideas of the familiar with the
unexpected the sort of political with
the playful the activists with consumer
and the expert with the amateur I think
you'll see elements of that in some of
the work here let me just start off with
a kind of vision here not many people
maybe know this particular project this
is operation moon watch it was started
in 1955 by Fred Whipple who said let's
go out and train people how to observe
satellites as they orbit the Earth and
he got port essentially amateurs to get
together and trained to do this the
interesting thing is this predates the
launch of Sputnik itself so in fact he
was actually sort of thinking ahead and
saying I know what's coming I know what
we should start looking at and training
for and in fact when Sputnik did launch
it was a huge political event but in
fact his group Fred Whipple's group was
pretty much in the best position to
start reporting about it and I'm
delivering information about tracking it
and I think that a lot of times that's
actually we do in research right we sort
of have to envision something that
doesn't exist yet but i also like this
theme of having everyday citizens be
involved and somehow participating and
contributing to science in an
interesting way give you another example
here this is uh well I everyone
recognizes of course this is supernova
2008 H a the other thing that's more
interesting about it is actually Carolyn
more so this is Carolyn Moore she's a
high school student in Warwick
New York and she's the one that
discovered this particular supernova
which has some really interesting unique
properties now it's fair to say that
Carolyn has more probably telescopes and
most people in the room but you could
make the same argument about maybe what
about what kinds of sensing do we have
and certainly our mobile phones do a lot
more sensing and let all of our
electronics are technologies and
essentially some of the things that we
talk about is sophisticated really
rapidly or not wasn't that long ago but
it was very exotic to have a laser
printer at your disposal so I just want
to kind of remind you of that and one
thing I'm very interested in these
participation by essentially expert
amateurs and it's not just in the
sensing in the observation think it's
also in the making this is a project by
Marcus Kaiser that is called solar
center so this is a 3d printer it's
designed to kind of capitalize on the
abundance of energy and raw material so
it takes the Sun it drives the 3d
printer it focuses the light and it
actually centers the sand which is in
abundance as well and it allows you to
sort of create objects here's something
printed on the solar center so nice
little Bowl it's amazing this this is
this was basically done as an mfa
project from the Royal College of Art
and i do want to sort of have some
threads of art in here especially coming
from new media and i think the one thing
that I like about bringing in art into
the critique so this is a quote I
particularly like the work of art is
valuable only in so far it is is it is
vibrated by the reflexes of the future
so often we talk about technologist is
the one engaging in the future but
artists are interested in this these
concept as well let me come back to this
space-themed because it's a nice one to
kind of make another point here we have
the sort of classic vision of you know
putting a person on the moon and
returning them safely and the argument
is of course humanity sort of celebrated
in this moment it was a big achievement
but the people that really were kind of
the ground troops so to speak are the
kind of brave engineers and scientists
of the day now I don't know what the new
sort of
problems might be that we might tackle
it might be things around biology might
be fam and healthcare issues about the
environment and all these I think we've
heard a lot about them even in the
recent presidential debates but
certainly computer sciences engineers
will play a significant role in these
kinds of solutions but I think we need
to also consider the role of these kind
of expert amateurs these people that are
essentially helping measure and report
and come together to do problem solving
and I think that we can facilitate this
with building the tools and actually
here at Stanford you have some really
great you know faculty and students
initiating a lot of this work as well
I'm going to I'll talk about this idea
of micro volunteerism in a minute but
let me um motivate this a little more
because i think most people get this but
this is a nice quote from illenore oster
who's won the nobel prize a couple years
ago she says bureaucrats sometimes do
not have the correct information while
citizens and users of resources do most
of us get this I know my Park I know my
bus I know my neighborhood I know you
know a lot more about what's going on
than what's coming out of say city
government or even you know state
government things like that now the
interesting thing is that these kinds of
problems that we were kind of alluding
to before unlike putting a man on the
moon and returning them so when we're
talking about things such as how do we
solve health care how do we solve
environmental global warning these are
actually a class of problem that are
much more difficult to understand
they're typically referred to as wicked
problems which is a sort of
classification that horse riddle
articulated a couple decades ago and the
idea is these are sort of societal level
problems they're often very sort of
difficult to solve they're incomplete
they're difficult to even describe what
they are and they have these kind of odd
side effects and I'm going to talk a
little bit how design research can allow
us to at least approach them and that's
what I feel a lot of myself and my
colleagues do and we try to actually
have conversations about various
proposed partial solutions and things in
this space and I'll say more about
design research
but largely I want to make sure that we
are sort of most of you are familiar
because there's the d.school here and
there's a lot of interaction at least in
HCI about design but i'm not i'm not
talking about designing like industrial
design talking about design in terms of
an inquiry focused on producing a
contribution of knowledge ok let's just
play a little game here for a second so
let's just pretend we're going to solve
street crime ok ok here's a solution
let's disarm the police ok that could
possibly solve sweet corn we could
repeal laws so we could actually kind of
redefine what it means protected commit
a crime that kind of also actually saw
some part of street crime we could have
some kind of ethical control in place of
sort of courts and other systems we
could just shoot criminals that would
obviously be a part of solving this if
you wanted to go that direction we could
give things away and disincentivize the
entire idea of street crime and I think
all of us have to partially agree that
there's a solution in all of these but
they also create a lot of other problems
and these are the kind of wicked
problems that are hard to just simply as
an engineering approach proposed a
solution measure a result and sort of
move on now the good news is I think
that some of the new things that with
design research and the sum of the HCI
approaches and all these
interdisciplinary approaches of having
other practitioners involved in the
debate help people to understand and
move some dialogue forward about these
kind of wicked problems I'll just say
this to emphasize again often these are
words that come up I think when you talk
about design i would say these are words
that kind of come up more when you talk
about design research i'll just like
highlight a couple of them in contrast
so like i said rather than problem
solving off of your problem making often
instead of into the service of industry
you're sort of in the service of society
things around where you might be talking
about consumers of what you're making
you might be talking about citizens and
and some kind of like lifestyle it's
less about commodities and buying but
more about getting people to think so
keep that in mind I
not going to offer sort of definition of
design but I do think this is a nice
categorization design isn't everything
we make but it's also between those
things its a mix of craft science
storytelling propaganda and philosophy I
think it kind of captures a lot of the
nuance of what the sort of scoping can
be yes if you had a project that was
clearly solving a problem like the
filter drinking straw in Africa that
might be for society is opposed to for
industry and we probably still call that
design more than his own research so I'm
not sure that it's necessarily a mix of
five or it makes a man rich that the
syllogism right I shouldn't come beyond
so strict as if everything's black and
white I'm trying to argue more that
often when you start to operate and the
things don't feel like they're objects
that would be produced in sort of mass
or marketed or maybe don't serve a
useful purpose beyond a limited kind of
framing of people or contacts that
there's still value in doing it and
that's where the agenda of design
research can you can leverage it but
it's fair to say there's certainly
things that are in the service of
society there was a great example that
are a design sort of objects I don't
want to kind of put things in one bucket
or the other HD they go the dividing
line goes in saving your place okay yeah
I think like with all these things
there's more nuanced so yeah oh sorry is
where you're calling design research
kind of the same thing it's a critical
design this practice or I think it um II
criticals not sort of a part of our
component of design research I think I
mean it's sort of a one way of
operationalizing it i think that's that
it's going great okay good yeah please
jump in I don't mean to certify it's
good to have a little dialogue going on
so I'll tell you a little bit about some
projects and that we can maybe that'll
be a little bit more framing perhaps so
I after I left Berkeley and I went off
Intel research and I founded this group
called urban atmospheres that looked at
sort of observing public spaces and
looking for opportunities for technology
to merge on those landscapes it was sort
of a proactive archaeology of urban life
in some sense and had a lot of code of
wonderful colleagues that I work with
through the years here and I'm not going
to go into all these projects I just
want to paint in broad strokes that some
of them are things you might expect like
mobile phones and applications others
are things that are a little unusual
there's trash cans and park benches and
some other kinds of objects and
experiences all designed not to be final
products with design that prompts you
about different engagements and also to
critique the culture that n milieu that
they're sitting in that's that's a big
part of what we do I'll briefly talk
about one of them and this was a project
I did with Elizabeth Goodman well and it
was looking at familiar strangers so
these are basically people are familiar
to you it's the person you see every
week at the bus stop it's that kid
always riding the skateboard down your
street it's that lady with her dog
there's they're familiar but they're
strangers so the thing is it is actually
a real relationship it's a relationship
in which you both mutually agree to
ignore each other without any
implications of hostility right so if
you ignore your friend that actually
means something but society just the way
that it operates this has been studied
by a lot of sociologists and others that
this is a real relationship and so we're
interested in what how does technology
change this and again I'm not going to
go through the whole study i'm just
going to kind of cut to one element that
fell out of this which was looking at
the idea of well what if you could
detect the kinds of people around you
and you actually knew where you were
with them for example you may be where
at coffee shops so the coffee cups
represent people that are nearby that
you might have been at a local coffee
shop in your neighborhood or maybe it's
color-coded by the how many how many
people are new or how many people are
sort of familiar strangers nearby and it
was designed to give you a new map or
new lens into the place around you now
none of you probably think this is novel
at all this is in a huge list of
products that we currently use I can't
possibly
them all now but certainly were used in
knowing about location and connections
to social networks that are nearby
network but also kind of physical in
space but the thing I want to kind of
point to is when we were doing this
project I actually was inspired by some
work by stanley milgram who's a social
psychologist who would look at this
exact same phenomenon decades before
this is a picture from his study outside
and the Bronx out of train platform
where he studied how people remembered
individuals similarly we were also
inspired by artists so one of them was
actually Vito konchi who has an art
piece that you're welcome to yourself
it's to find a stranger in public and
follow them until they go into a private
place so this could last a couple
minutes if they get in a taxi cab or
ours if they end up sitting in a state a
crowded theater I'm not going to
guarantee you don't get arrested doing
this but you could welcome to do this
performance the point was that we found
ourselves drawing from technologists
sociologists and also artists and as
Scott alluded to I also worked with John
Candy my advisor at the time and we did
these floating blimps and they flew
around this is also inspired of course
by the vivarium project and some of the
work that Alan Kay had done and it was
about sort of telepresence and having a
remote body and the way these moved
around and I'm not going to talk about
this project but this project was also
inspired by some work by an artist Andy
Warhol who did a project called silver
clouds if you happen to go to Pittsburgh
you have a great you can actually go in
this exhibit and interact with them but
the idea is that this there's sort of
this connection between art and
technology that got me thinking a little
bit more about what this could mean and
it remind me of project by a friend
Michael named Mark who worked on this
Aspen movie map project and the idea was
he created this laser video disc I know
it's amazing that you could actually
have a touch screen and you can walk
around the city of Aspen and you know I
thought gee that seems like something
else that I know about and it's not to
say that if Michael had never done this
we would have never gotten
Google Street View I'm not making that
claim but I'm saying often artists are
dismissed as they're doing something
pretty they're doing something that
doesn't really pertain to what the real
discussion is with technology and
society and in fact Michael had it right
sort of 30 years before the interesting
thing to note is that Michaels project
which by the way looks almost the same
here right Michael actually got he was
awarded a Golden Fleece award so I'm not
sure how many people I had well Terry
and Scott couple of note the Golden
Fleece Awards award given out by
Congress for the most egregious waste of
taxpayer dollars so they looked at this
and said this is a waste of money this
is ridiculous we should not be funding
anything like this so so I just
literally sort of SAT around I was
having a little discussion with goal on
Levin who is a colleague of mine and we
were just coming up with some other good
ones here so I think kind of camera
based computing really starts around
sort of Myron Kruger who did some really
early work in this and now of course
have Microsoft Kinect and I toy but
again artist sort of initiating some of
the early exploration that space Jeffrey
Shaw's legible city and a lot of kind of
fitness exercise equipment artcom did
something that's very similar to what
emerges sort of Google Earth a graffiti
writer by the Institute for applied
economy if any of you watch tour de
france a couple years ago then you saw a
nike chalk bot very similar a good
friend and colleague can go over who did
the tell a garden looks kind of there's
a lot of farmville connections here and
i notice this 20 to 30 year gap and i
think I don't just kind of getting old
I'm noticing these things but I just
this is just you can just do this all
day graffiti research lab and then this
really badly named graffiti by agents of
change all-natural coke by Red Bull okay
sir two years later and then hands from
above which is a sort of urban project
done by chris o'shea which let kind of a
video monitor you can sort of pick
people up from the video and this do
thing so again
and that the point is also that these
people are not even giving credit so
these are just kind of blatant ripoff
people here might remember sort of
context photography that Lars Erik and
Maria Hawkinson did looking at how
photography and lomography could play a
role in kind of filtering pictures looks
a lot like Instagram to me it kind of
got it wrong because it should have been
a little bit more about sort of the
context and even I pulled this is the
class project from a class called that
Iran at CMU Daisy km where some students
basically said what if you had this
lifelogging camera they got an a they
got 360 thousand dollars they said why
didn't we do kick stars that it didn't
exist in we weren't really that wasn't
there so and then I oh start finished
with this example because it's a good
one Twitter actually Jack Dorsey says
yeah I saw text mob which is an art
project done by Institute for applied
economy and said yeah that inspired this
project and I I think that we need to
sort of draw more of a literal
connection between their artists that
are engaged in these kinds of debates
and there was a actually see piece know
who wrote about this in this book the
two cultures where you literally outline
there's two cultures in our society
wrote in the 1950s in the UK and he says
the clashing point of two subjects of
two disciplines two cultures of two
galaxies ought to produce creative
chances and I think that's this
challenge that's still with us right
that we there's a missed opportunity
that things should happen here now I had
a chance for a number of years I've
collaborated with a group survival
research labs here the Bay Area not so
much when I was away at sea of you but
this is chance to look at a lot of
things that I think are relevant now
even with the current research things
about DIY culture about reuse about sort
of bringing science and art into some
kind of connected fabric and
I'll bring this down for a second but we
could have separate critique of this
kind of art and we can talk about it but
I think some things that are certainly
here are there is a critique of the
culture of the technology of machines of
control of chance there is a sort of
dramatic actually script to these
although it looks very chaotic there's a
narrative to to each of these kinds of
performances in some sense there's also
a mandate to release the most amount of
energy in the shortest time possible
which is sort of an interesting
engineering mandate but this also as I
mentioned before I was doing things with
telepresence and it wasn't really part
of the official agenda of what I was
publishing at I Triple E and acai but I
was interested in other issues that were
also around telepresence epistemological
issues around what's real who's
responsible so with Mark and other
colleagues we built machines and
mechanisms and let people actually fire
sore lethal weapons and give control
over to other people not because we were
trying to be out of control and
dangerous we wanted to actually question
where the sort of line should be drawn
when people start to actually interact
across distances we were curious about
what was even real as a project I did
with Ken Goldberg and Judith donath and
others to explore at what point would
you actually be considered committing a
crime over the internet if we let people
actually kind of burn and do different
kind of damage to currency of course if
the currency is real and experiments
real that in fact there's some criminal
behavior because you can't manipulate
and damage US currency I did some other
projects with a group that i started
called the experiment or action unit
where i actually designed this device
called an eye balm which is actually a
electromagnetic pulse device so
questioning this is all sort of pre 911
but can i own this kind of thing can i
operate this kind of device a little bit
of it was to push back on we talked
about establishing national parks and
places that are sort of free from
highways and roads are we going to have
places that are free from technology how
will we push back will there be ways to
guarantee that the
is actually no electronics operational
in a certain range and of course there's
this sort of absurdity to it but it's
actually functional and sort of you have
to kind of address it similarly some
projects around looking at biological
kinds of warfare and manufacturing this
is a project at ARS electronica number
of years called dispersion which is a
pathogen vending machine which sir
prompted you to have a very playful
experience because it was visceral and
engaging but then this sort of moral
dilemma when things fell out at the
bottom and you weren't sure what to do
with those and how to handle those and
you have to operate through a
fingerprint recognition we knew who you
were it was this kind of very kind of
ethical dilemma and then never other
projects I'm not going to really go into
these but I think I want to come back to
another quote about the kind of art
critique here so I like art because I
think art throws off the covers that
hide the expressiveness of experience
things it quickens us from the slackness
of routine and enables us to forget
ourselves by finding ourselves in the
delight of experiencing the world about
us in its very qualities and forms and I
think that that I like that because it's
sort of this idea that often by taking
another viewpoint you open up some new
framing to a problem and you don't even
have to really do this as an art
practice even as an engineer as a
designer to look at something very
differently it's a big part of this way
to innovate there's a little bit of a
shift here but I want to make a point
about actually engineering and how
difficult it is and how difficult the
job of even designing novel kinds of
experiences so this is actually a quote
from some individual to help design the
lunar lander for the moon it says if a
major project is truly innovative you
cannot possibly know it's exact cost at
its exact schedule at the beginning and
in fact if you do know the exact cost
and exact schedule chances are that the
technology is obsolete so I think in
this this probably resonate with the PhD
students were like when is it going to
be done like how far do I have to go but
it's hard you have to pick something you
have to do something that's kind of you
can't even fully describe this is the
huge challenge that I think
lot of us face I was thinking back
recently about the the props that Scott
had mentioned and it is true that was
two thousand or so when Terry invited me
here and I don't know why he agreed to
this but I said I'll do you use this
proper than having me up here and it
worked out so it was this really great
moment but when that was envisioned this
is what was on my desk okay just to give
you an idea that it's really cool kick
ass pentium i was using mosaic I had
Alta Vista fired up good to go and the
social networking at the time maybe the
well or use net that's about what you
were probably had and my advisor was
really cool so he bought me this Palm
Pilot so I was this mobile I was just
really cool and it's hard to envision
what the future will be now it seems
very obvious this if this was sitting in
front of you it was very hard to say
yeah that's it that was a really big
leap at the time and of course there's a
lot of these now lots of different
products that resemble this someone just
recently sent me this cool little family
tree and then I actually found you end
up never looking at your thesis I went
and looked at my thesis these are
pictures from it and then here's
pictures from this year from some
advertising from these companies that
you'll hang out in factories and hang
out with your friends you use a tablet
to control it we had that so it was
about 17 years out but we kind of had
that vision but that was very hard to
come up with and in fact now there's so
many of these but that's the exciting
part of this it seems like the the
playing field is so level now that lots
of people could participate and innovate
and I really want to say something about
this idea of the rise of the expert
amateur these makers and builders I'm
very interested in this kind of framing
I already told you about the solar
center this is a PCR device for actually
replicating DNA this is the kind of
concept toy maker for kids my own son
just recently said dad does he have to
have a 3d printer so this is the next
generation this is how they think but
it's from proprietary innovation to
populist innovation is
not to say that the Academy and an
industry will not be part of this will
just play very different roles but very
important role so it's kind of trying to
understand what that is and I think part
of it is being able to kind of really
disrupt things and be playful with them
so I had this manifesto but this I pull
out one quote from it we want our
technologies to sing of not just
productivity but the love of curiosity
the joy of wonderment and the freshness
of the unknown and it's not to say that
we don't want technologies that actually
help us solve problems I mean I want to
get to the caltrain on time I want to
find some cool restaurants when I'm in
an unfamiliar town but I also want my
technologies to prompt me to be curious
and reflect and engage in different ways
and I think a big part of it from an
educational standpoint is we really need
people to envision lots of ideas and
ideation I like this quote from a
designer fraud innovative innovation
companies today don't ask and don't care
about basic skills and grades or s80
scores instead they want to know if you
can brainstorm all the possible uses of
bubble wrap right and it's almost this
value of creativity right so less grades
and gres more what's your github profile
what's your instructable setup look like
what's your Kickstarter profile right
these kind of different ways of looking
at things but as an educator I feel that
I really sort of res the other statement
resonates with me if we were possible to
define generally the mission of
education it could be said that its
fundamental purpose is to ensure that
all students benefit from learning in
ways of love and who participate fully
in public community creative and
economic life so it's a really sort of
tall order to figure out it's not just
these sort of fundamentals but a really
deeper engagement a little bit more
provocative here but uh in the three
ecologies talks about in order to
converge with the perspective of the art
world scientists must demonstrate that
they have abandoned their white lab
coats beginning with those invisible
ones that they wear in their heads in
their language and in the way they
conduct themselves so partially it's
trying to find a playing field where it
sort of we can all kind of
operationalize the things
we do so now I'm just going to try to
focus more on to a couple other example
projects that I've done with some
students so I run this living
environments lab which looks at this
kind of critical intersection between
people technology and the environment or
that the planet in some sense and I'm
not going to talk about all these are
some kind of high-level themes but they
do fit into these kind of three
ecologies these are the my sort of
primary instigators these are the
graduate students that have worked with
me most recently stacy kuznetsov James
Pierce and sun yong kim who are kind of
largely responsible for almost all the
really cool content that i show you try
to point that out so the one thing I do
want that I'm really interested in is
citizen science and I do you want to
talk a little bit more about that and we
have these this is kind of one of those
canonical examples of a christmas bird
watch people going out and watching
birds and while a lot of people feel I
couldn't really do that I don't know
what they're talking about identifying
Birds it ends up that even amateurs and
this is very much example of sort of
crowdsourcing that it ends up great
creating great sort of long-term bird
population data but other thing i like
about citizen science is it almost
touches back and harkens to an early
childhood about counting things in your
yard and observing the world and unique
and interesting ways being curious
learning and reflecting and I think the
other opportunities to look at how of
course technologies have accelerated
this idea of mobile tech of citizen
science so the mobile phone is at least
one of many sites so we can use to kind
of investigate how to look at the world
because the phone is you know no longer
communication tool right it's a sort of
supercomputer radio station with sensors
okay I can't possibly list all the
related projects but just in sort of
broad strokes again a lot of them are
about having people crowd source and
collect information and analyze it
things around environmental issues but
also things around discovering and
categorizing galaxies and invasive
plants things like that
so I'll give you a couple examples of
some projects we did with a little bit
more detail so one of those a project we
did early on in in Ghana in Africa this
was allowing taxicab drivers to go
around and collect data using sensors
not this sensor the iphone did not even
exist when we did this project that's
the separate one just for visual sorry
that's on the same slide but they
collected data about carbon oxide a
bunch of other chemicals the red dots
show where data was collected the
interesting thing is we want to just
figure out would the maps look different
would people actually get nuances around
where air quality varied throughout the
day and it was kind of just to gather
some pictures so that we could sort of
have ground truth about what data would
look like collected by citizens kind of
the more interesting thing because we
got the graphs and we could look at all
the pictures the more interesting thing
was that when people brought these back
they started telling these stories about
oh yeah the numbers were really high so
I took the ring road into town oh I was
really worried my car was a polluter so
I brought mine in to have it looked at
so in fact it was the stories that we
gave people the small lens and remember
it wasn't even designed to give them any
information that was not part of the
study but they looked at the number
nonetheless and it got them to kind of
have a behavior change and I kind of
call that sort of like this Prius effect
right so when you're driving behind
someone they're trying to get to that
100 mile per gallon I can get there
you're like just get there so I can go
around you but anyway when people have
that visual then it starts to play if
they start to sort of have illegibility
about it and interact with it and use it
now of course we're interested in how
mobile devices play a role in changing
behavior allowing you to do citizen
science but we also looked at indoor
kind of fixed monitoring so this was the
same way you could imagine what if
instead of looking at your friends
online status you could look at all your
friends indoor air quality in their
homes so that was part of this study
that sun-young did and again it really
interesting cuz people suddenly observe
how their friends were behaving and they
would call them what happened like I
burnt the dinner it's like they could
sort of see it was happening but people
learned about when they opened their
doors or vacuumed or did different
activities how it influenced the air
and again not part of the study but
there were some individuals that
actually quit smoking as a result
because there's was so off the chart and
they didn't understand I thought wow I
thought it was just a little bit higher
but it was much different I'll say a
little bit more about mobile in the
public place them in a in the following
so another study that i was i did with
allison Woodruff and Paul Aoki and
others was to actually say well what if
we put sensing on to the infrastructure
so the city of San Francisco they let us
put some sensors on to municipal street
sweepers there are some reasons why
that's a bad choice but there's also
reasons why that's a good choice that's
the setup you can see the good part of
that is street sweepers with about only
a half dozen or maybe even a dozen
street sweepers you can cover the whole
city every couple days because they go
down every single Street the hidden
application was that I could have told
you right when to move your car when the
street super was coming we didn't like
build that app but I did have that in
mind but you get these kind of
visualizations and people looking at the
city and looking at how data is
collected people often often want to
know you know where the bad parts and
you know some of it's somewhat expected
things around the hunters point or
higher concentration at other areas and
I'm not going to go into sort of all the
details of the study but to point out
that I think the solution moving forward
is going to be certainly the
infrastructure participating with people
and other kinds of communities so
speaking of communities uh Stacey
because nuts off looked at exactly that
problem of what happens if we give
people in different communities these
sensors so we gave some to bicyclists to
a homeless community to some parents to
some activists and this is in Pittsburgh
but they move these around really
differently and it's probably what you
would expect but it was nice to see
these results that people want to tell
different stories about their city they
want to tell different things about
their community and so collecting the
data and they were able to move these
around and put them up wherever they
wanted was a big part of understanding
how they would negotiate as a as a
collective what they want to do and what
kind of narrative they want to tell the
other thing which I knew was going to
happen was that
anything that looks as excited as we are
about having a sort of ubiquitous
computing be in the future if it doesn't
look a mobile phone it's a bomb so tons
of calls from the police department
confiscations I mean admittedly these
are very kind of odd looking so I'll
give you that and I kind of knew that
was going to happen but it brings the
question do we want to have these kind
of sensing technologies be very legible
and read it should it be like a metal
box with the flashing light or does it
look like a sort of lost teddy bear in
the sort of city or is it hidden should
it be visible it's an interesting
question that we're trying to look at
and also looked at how you might
experience these data sets so of course
things with maps and mobile phones but
maybe there's new kinds of signage in
cities to prompt you about the cleanest
direction rather than the shortest
direction through a city we this is the
project that Sun Yong Kim did where she
looked at actually embedding it into
clothing so now you actually have a
shirt that has this measurement device
and it responds to the air quality and
some other playful designs the thing
about the t-shirt just to point out was
that this was interesting because now
before I might participate by having
some mobile application I download it
and I use it but in the future are sorry
in the in the t-shirt case imagine you'd
walk into a bar and your friends would
say what is that go outside now why is
it higher out they're coming here wait
go in the bathroom wake okay get in my
car okay so the person becomes this kind
of proactive dialogue about the issue
rather than just buried in a kind of
mobile application we looked at how
there'd be new ways of kind of almost
doing graffiti this was a project stay
seated or these were robots that were
magnetic you would kind of throw them up
like throw ease but then they had motors
they would climb up walls and buildings
and take measurements and do things and
you can kind of bang on the wall and
they come down and we also looked at
sort of how low cost could you make
these and these are just different
designs exploring a lot of different
parts of the technical elements down to
about fifteen twenty dollars but I kind
of
this idea of what we're calling
spectacle computing so often of course
we want computing to be very transparent
to disappear in the background the
common vision and ubiquitous computing
but what about these strategies were you
intentionally and overtly want to draw
attention to particular issue so these
were again air quality balloons they lit
up based on different kinds of
pollutants that they measured in the air
and the idea was that people would see
these balloons they come up they see
what's going on we would handle one to
them and then all of a sudden now
they're part of the sensing
infrastructure they start walking around
their friends ask what it is I'll bring
it to my house to check thing I'm going
to bring it over to my kids school I
wonder what's happen in this park and it
creates this very different kind of
model of how people can participate in
this dialogue about sensing that's
that's very different structure than
standard sort of sensing on a phone or
something like that but I say we
actually questioned even what a sensor
is and I think it's a separate issue we
could say what is a sensor you know the
certain idea about what that might look
like but we said well even if you look
around there's lots of things that have
kind of nothing to do with technology
plants the way bees behave the way fish
behave that tell you a lot if you know
how to read them and we interviewed a
bunch of people who did this who use
technology or they were not luddites but
could easily read into the environment
what was happening we got very
interested in these kind of biomarkers
or ways that kind of new ways of seeing
I would say so Stacey primarily looked
at this but the idea was that rather
than always looking down on your device
to look at information what if there
were also prompts to look around get a
sort of some overview and then also in a
hybrid approach use the technology and
she's gone did some more work in this
biosensing with more community
engagement these are sort of various
columns that actually measure lead in
various soil samples and they sort of
there's a digital element and there's a
biological element and we really
interested in how to design that kind of
interface and interconnects between them
to create compelling experiences
alright so I want to come back to this
idea alluded to before micro
volunteerism so this is like a I think
this a little more broad than citizen
science so you might imagine
volunteering for you know you might go
to a weekend beach cleanup you might
volunteer for a couple weekends for
Habitat for Humanity you may list in the
military or the Peace Corps for multiple
years or go way to teach abroad these
are different models of volunteering but
what does it mean when you know i'm on
the corner of you know mane and third
and i have 47 seconds I'll volunteer 47
seconds and it's a lot of actually
problems that people are looking at
Michael's looking at this and I know a
lot of people are of how can you
actually take advantage of this
cognitive surplus as clay shirky calls
it I actually love this quote that just
got pulled out from a bomb of the other
night the role of citizen in our
democracy does not end with your vote so
in some sense it's obviously a call a
further participation in different ways
I think that that fits in well to these
models of how we can engage people in
sensing and and other kinds of
strategies so here's your sort of
typical sort of citizen science project
right you know her Susan she sees this
invasive beetle on the plant so she goes
oh takes the picture she uploads it and
the sort of scientist or sort of policy
maker gets it they get a bunch of
information they sort of crowdsource
this they make some collective action
and you know they solve the problem in
some some end game so the interesting
thing is when we do these projects we've
done a couple of them people go hey that
was cool whatever the thing you did
about the Beatles I don't care about
beetles I care about idling buses or I
care about some other issue so for a
while we were doing all these various
instantiation of citizen science
projects we've got more interested in
allowing people to kind of make their
own so the idea and others are looking
at this too but how could Susan they say
I want to compose my own campaign and I
want people to whatever take a picture
or have a
comment field and this is similar to a
lot of work where people are doing kind
of remote sort of collection of forms
and things even actually the butterfly
stuff that Scott did a number of years
ago is in this same genre of looking at
how people can actually compose in a
sort of non programmatic way the kinds
of things they want to capture and
report it's also how they can kind of
manage it in in real time so how they
can sort of see the different people
coming in and how there's almost a
subscription model so i might be in
stanford for a couple of days and i
would say i wonder if there's any
interesting campaigns i would want to be
a part of and i could subscribe to them
and say oh great i'll be parts of those
and maybe they pertain to me because as
a parent i care about them or maybe as a
Californian I care about them or some
other issue the other thing and this is
where there's more expertise here to
look at this but this I evil will debate
and sort of essentially make decisions
about the data and I think actually a
lot of work that you know Jeff's been
looking at in some of his students about
how do you visualize these datasets how
do you make action on them based on
different ways of viewing them and sort
of interacting with them so let me pause
it a couple open areas of exploration I
think you're interesting in this citizen
science from our experience one is that
there needs to be more sensor
flexibility in terms of contacts so I
showed you some examples around air
quality we talked about beetles and
other things but maybe you're in the
Central Valley of California it's really
about pesticide so there should be some
way to very flexibly exchange these
kinds of sensing sensors and apps in
some sense another one is looking at not
just the citizen science from sensing
but the analysis so this is a picture
from outside of Pittsburgh where there's
a lot of Marcellus Shale drilling and
there's a lot of runoff and sort of
pollutions around this but the issue is
there I might not be mere this in
California to really take pictures and
help you involve but maybe I concerns me
but I could participate in terms of
analyzing the data
like the things that are on some of the
other projects I showed before from
other individuals looking at sort of
analyzing data and and again Michaels
done a lot of this as well another thing
that seems to be really vital is for
grounding contributions so having people
actually know that their data made a
difference your data is downloaded by
the EPA we change that bus la trappe
route by your house based on some
reports just letting people know that
the data is being used and active what
the story when I tell it people get go
this is great i would love to
participate and i believe them but I
just don't think they're really going to
do it in week 72 I think it's it's going
to be a burden right so I'm really
interested in the longer term studies
can't ignore badges right Ike if someone
had told me a little 25 by 25 pixel you
know icons really mattered I would have
probably dismissed it many years ago but
people love these rewards and badges and
in fact you can imagine relooking at
this not from the sense of being a mayor
of a space but maybe being the citizen
scientists of a place unlocking a
microclimate by collecting enough
information are enough data you know
being that kind of citizen scientists of
a lake or stream or unlocking the rivers
and streams badge and I think games of
play are going to be a big part of this
because a lot of the sort of front end
of the systems we design look very sort
of scientific still and i think there
could be playful ways to have them more
as games so something where individuals
instead of looking at the magic game
where say bumblebees were some kind of
game element and you knew where the
bumblebees were to get point or
something like that but in fact that was
really just pollen measurements around
your city so you would already sort of
be sort of indirectly learning about
pollen and pollen density and seasons
but maybe you say i want to create my
own bumblebee so then you start
measuring the pollen counts and put your
own bumblebees into the game something
like that where you're kind of can
scaffold up into different involvement
and maybe you're happy with that but
maybe you actually scaffold up into sort
of a more a role we're kind of running
the game or running the campaign and
finally this idea of what a sensor is I
just think somehow we're thinking really
narrowly about it I mean
could be you know why don't sort of
children's you know dump trucks and
diggers have soil sensors on them and
dogs and I already told you about some
of the other projects here but it's not
to say that they should be scientific
and frightening and scary but children
obviously as they learn they should
think that objects will help them be
smart and kind of reflect about the
environment in just very playful ways
and I just sort of posit that I don't
have any sort of final designs but I
think there's huge opportunities and
moving away from things that look like
strange probes that people are holding
out and taking measurements okay last
project I want to talk to you about is
about energy and this is some work with
James Pierce who's been largely leading
this effort and the idea is that
certainly right now electricity for
example you plug into the wall and it's
it's pretty uniform and it works and it
functions and that's that's a good thing
but we could we think about it in a
different way so i'll give you an overly
sappy example with my now well it's like
now not in Halloween costumes son so
imagine he goes up and he's swinging
during the day but he generates a little
bit of electricity just a little bit and
he brings that home to me and then that
night sort of read from the light
generated from that so is that different
than just plugging into the wall that's
the question so I would claim it is I
mean this is it was handcrafted it's a
gift it has emotional value it's very
sentimental and in some sense it's
exactly what Walter Benjamin talks about
with the aura of objects and he talks
about it more art framing but it's the
same thing the authenticity of a thing
is the essence of all that is
transmissible from its beginning ranging
from its substantive duration to its
testimony to the history which it has
experienced and I'll come back to that
in a second because right now we just
really plug in and kind of forget about
it what if we knew more about where the
energy came from so is it fresh is its
tail as a hydroelectric is it
was it generated you know somehow far
away or nearby right now when most of
the time we talk about energy and sort
of problem solving we talk about well
we're consuming too much energy we need
to figure out ways to reduce the
consumption so and that's extremely
useful but at least when James and I
look at this we say well actually
there's these other things what about
how people could collect energy what
about how they share thing what about
how they could keep it those are other
opportunities for people to have some
kind of experience with energy and there
might be design opportunities in that
landscape too it's not to say this is
the wrong one but I think there's more
missed opportunity so and if people do
this now right so some people are more
sophisticated they have energy they're
producing and they just put it back in
the grid right you can imagine other
policies sort of I'm collecting this
energy but I actually I want to share
with other people in my block I want to
share with other people that have dogs I
want to share with other people who you
know are at a different sort of economic
status in me or whatever there could be
different policies right now we don't
really relate to it in that way I mean
you could almost think about computer
science terms which everybody's probably
familiar with here and saying well what
would you know energy metadata about
where it came from what would that look
like what would kind of social issues
around energy you shared it does it have
the same kind of textural quality could
you crowdsource energy and do things
actually an interesting thing is we sort
of we were looking at the work from the
Kaiser distribution with the pad tab
board it ends up there's these very
distinct ways to actually harvest energy
that are exactly that scale sort of
finger like arm like and body like so
it's a really nice kind of mapping that
we looked at in terms of kind of 1 10
100 watts that you can kind of get at
these are a couple other design prompts
so in one of them is a seasonal energy
lamp it just says essentially could you
look at the kinds of energy that's
available so is it sunny out or is it is
there a lot of hydroelectric now so you
have some reflection about it you could
think of it this way where right now
would you get off the bus and say I'm
going to leave a couple jewels here
behind for my
drive my bus riders with me would you
exchange energy in this fluid way we
don't even really see it visibly right
so we don't have these kinds of
interfaces and it's sort of strange
because it seems as if this would be
really informative about you know you'd
go to Iceland pick up some really
unusual energy maybe want to save it
that's special kinds of qualities to it
and then when you think about we did
some studies just looking at how people
interact with these devices and in fact
people largely even though they do the
same thing everybody consistently feels
these are more genuine these are more
sort of with the material they're sort
of provide this handcrafted pneus to
them and we've looked at how you could
actually design these mementos in some
sense that are these singular emotional
bits of energy so things that are you
could actually save up and exchange
small bits of energy another sort of
sappy example but it gets the point
would you and say your father turn a
hand-cranked together would you take
that and put it on the shelf with your
other heirlooms is that something that
you value and I'm not saying that all
that lots of like little bits of energy
does not an energy crisis solve but
different and novel engagements with
energy can lead to new thinking about
other problem solving in this space that
right now is largely a grid that we
don't really have interface or access
with and this is just some some of the
set of technologies we've built to do
this and this is the last piece I want
to talk about which is just another
energy project this was an art piece
that ARS electronica that I did this
year on energy parasites so the idea
here is that well there's places where
energy sort of see peeks out of the
environment can we kind of harvest it or
almost steal it from different places
and reuse it and repurpose it in
different ways so you know could you put
it onto a tram or a bart or it would run
through and you have this wind energy
and now you'd say well I charge my phone
to this wind energy I'm going to call my
friend with the wind energy from bart or
I'm going to bring back some subway
energy from another city or we did a lot
of different variations of this right so
it would it be things with a gutter
where the water will be flowing or it
could be something on a handrail where
it's we put it into sort of different
stores here around the Bay Area
Europe where you could actually sort of
harvest it off of handrails and you
could put a water fountain they're just
on a handrail the one down here is
actually you stick onto a car steals a
little bit of electricity off someone's
head like then you grab it off later and
you charge your phone or something with
it but it's showing how you can
repurpose and reuse energy that we don't
think about we don't see this ray that
kind of small elements none of this is
solving sort of some energy crisis and
this is technically slowing down the
train you're not getting anything for
free right but it's prompting you to
think about opportunities for engagement
so with that I just want to thank my
students again and the national science
foundation the Heinz for supporting the
work financially and thank you for
having me back here it's just one of my
favorite venue so thank you again so it
also should say I'm looking for students
so because I just arrived at Berkeley so
you get to stay in the bay area I know
I'm not supposed to steal Stanford
students but I'm on the PR push go
somewhere else is here good okay ladies
in trouble here Michael some interesting
connections to things like see by where
light within an urban environment you
give people imagine wildflowers and just
toss them and it is in the grounds for
the youth at the small beautification of
the area holds makes a wonder whether
what you're sort of doing it or going to
get it is sensible I even get everyone
sort of legal it's of sensors or little
actuator tap into that serves the boy
trying to push holding you see something
well sort of it's certainly one thing I
so see bobbing is this great i love that
kind of analogy i thought about and we
thought about if you had that was a
little bit about the work Stacey did
with these sensors there a little bit we
did a smaller version of that where we
gave people somewhat non-functional
versions so they could be smaller just
to see what the design issues were but
would people scatter them around because
then it was really cheap for us to make
them and then all these weird prompts
about people did this they little
put on a toilet seat they put it on like
you know I don't want to sit in this
chair there's some weird there I want to
sense what they're there but it's it's
not only what you are saying about the
place by putting them there but then
also about when I see those it's telling
me like your reflections about it so I I
I love that it's clearly provocative
because you can imagine all of a sudden
you come out of your yard and there's
all these sensors like what are my
neighbors like worrying I'm like leaking
oil here what's going on I'm also
concerned that everything's about
environmental issues I mean I'm guilty
of that with our own projects but I'd
like to have it feel where yeah it could
be just playful like I just want to
count you know skateboarders and go by
here is just something fun and playful
because I think that will engage people
in thinking about how the tools I think
when people think about problem solving
they'll think very much what a lot of
stuff you're to doing to that you'll say
oh I will send out this kind of call to
arms and people respond and that's part
of how I'll answer big questions about
anything from you know the big issues we
get at but also little things I want it
to feel very fluid for them to do these
kinds of issues yeah there's a there's
interesting I mean I'm convinced any
good technology has bad sides to it and
this there's clearly a lot of bad things
in here it's the whole I can report bad
data and drive down your real estate in
your neighborhood also the Marcellus
Shale thing actually a lot of groups
were working with don't want to really
work with that because it's telling that
the gas industry where they're actually
watching them they would rather not have
them know where they're watching them so
it creates these kind of problems a lot
of issues Scott a number of your
research project makes people more aware
of resource than otherwise would be hey
all had the experience of like you're
camping and you have very limited amount
of fuel but become much more attentive
to how to use your pool
or money by virtue of being in the case
of quarters and dollars physical I worry
about if I drop a dime on the couch I'd
probably go ferreted out and there are
other resources that are much less
physically representative I waste an
equivalent amount of without even
worrying about so one thing that I
wasn't in the way the numbers of recent
projects are take something which
otherwise wouldn't be in your
attentional foreground and put it there
and whether that kind of present Miss
has effects beyond just that energy
what's of all energy or for other kinds
of space yeah that's a good question
actually I think so at least with energy
i think i think this actually is true
for almost all the projects certainly
the kind of more environmental ones
where current strategies are a lot of
them are about kind of guilting you out
really it's about sort of you should be
saving more you know you can save ten
cents here there's this you're
increasing the ozone layer all these
kind of issues whereas our strategy has
been let's just give people different
lens to see something with no sort of
part of the design prompting them one
way or the other and often they'll just
with this new information they'll
reflect on and take some action there
could be bad strategy with that but
certainly when people see things like
the air quality we saw we know we didn't
tell people what to do with it we didn't
create these kind of ominous interfaces
that sort of screamed at you and told
you about you know flee the room and
similar with the energy it was less
about you need to save it or just let me
just give you a little bit more lens of
what's happening you figure it out which
is it's kind of an art approach really
to sort of not present a full narrative
right yeah I don't know if that answers
that but it's certainly the strategy
that I'm more interested in it may be
less successful I'm completely open to
admitting that I just feel from a like a
design landscape there's a lot of stuff
going on in the other area so I'd like
to create dialogue in this and other
side of that I think the right solution
is all these is probably this hybrid
thing yes you'd like to have things
prompt you you know turn this off chain
something here but also where they could
be really disruptive and you know might
really you turn these things off if
they're not kind of immediately a little
bit playful and engaging that said
there's a problem because we did one I
didn't talk about it we did a project
sun-young did on actually Stacey did on
water conservation we put these into
bathrooms in public places and it let
you kind of visualize water use and you
kind of compare to other people that use
it and we tried out different interfaces
part of a study that we published but
the problem was it was too playful
people wasted water playing around with
it so yeah cautionary tale these things
go both ways so the fair critique how to
use crowdsourcing employees making way
for instance in lower reforms
Constitution reforms and such have you
seen any examples of integrating
gamification into poison making at that
kind of kind of complicated complex
build information but people are trying
to produce okay so the question is
around policymaking with crowdsourcing
basically yeah I think well a little bit
of a sort of plug there's a project at
Berkeley this date and democracy project
which is about how people can create
policies and look at essentially they're
voting issues and other people's and
kind of come you can you can essentially
get multiple people to weigh in about
their beliefs and you actually what kind
of comes out is often you're more
aligned with people than you think you
think that it's sort of I can't possibly
share the same views as Arnold
Schwarzenegger or something but then you
go actually a couple things that's a
rather surprising and I think some
things that we've thought about our
right now we just had election it's not
everyone's mind we had all these things
go on and we're always like how do you
feel about this policy and that's how
I'm voting but that sort of fades right
so could there be technologies to keep
an awareness about you know it was a
little bit more of a thought back when I
was in Pittsburgh but like oh they just
plowed my street with the snow that was
because this person got elected they
voted the meeting and just some way of
connecting me to aliveness of politics
in some way
that's not exactly i think what you're
asking but in some sense i think sharing
these ideas and coming to like solutions
it's good it i mean there's obvious you
know data there's all these projects
around even the Code for America folks
are doing a lot of things in the same
space so I'm not really probably the
right person to ask there's there's many
and I'm probably not speaking correctly
to all of them but I think there are
that's a very exciting topic yes yeah
sure charlize does the degree to Indian
policy would be the degree to which you
could integrate many of the wonderful
sensors that you're talking about into
larger patterns or larger inferences
about behavior or what could happen what
is happening I mean have you thought
about that aspect what would you like
when I describe this sort of the project
we're actually building that the one
that's kind of about citizen sign fillet
people form their own campaigns and
things it's it so but the issue is could
you have something where you almost
belong to these sort of cohorts or
tribes and you sort of and it would be
prompted so it's I don't know maybe not
in Palo I'll tell it off and I decided
to take a walk down here and then it
says hey we're missing some data from
this area could you take some
measurements we're trying to make a
decision about something or we have some
really strange data in this place could
you take some data here or maybe it's
some reward structure where if you are
out getting coffee we need you to take
four pictures of something along the way
so these kind of just-in-time prompts or
also like keeping people on reserve
which is a lot of strategies that have
been really successful that Michaels
looked at and others of I think that
that's a better solution where it's not
constantly in the foreground but you
feel involved enough that you're kind of
called to arms in some sense for these
brief instances I'm back to this micro
volunteerism I think as all these HCI
and design projects it's where's the
sweet spot because too little engagement
and then I forgotten about it too much
engagement and now it's annoying I don't
want to be part of that
and I don't know what the answer is but
we will do what we always do we will
experiment and we will celebrate and
commiserate and then we'll convene again
and figure out what's going on but it's
good to have that I like having that
dialogue now because I can tell that's
the future I want to live in I just
don't know how to dial it in right yeah
thanks great thank you all for letting
me come
you